A truly great product is ultimately defined...
...by the integration of its hardware and software.
Developing an iPhone with a larger and more advanced display...
...launched one of the most significant design and engineering efforts...
...since we introduced the original product.
With a 4.7 inch display, iPhone 6 becomes taller and wider.
We made the design dramatically thinner...
...while developing a smooth, continuous surface...
...that is comfortable to both hold and use.
We are also introducing iPhone 6 Plus with a larger 5.5 inch display.
And with the same continuous surfaces...
...and seamless material transitions as iPhone 6,...
...it's very thin.
With iPhone 6 and iPhone 6 Plus,...
...we've taken the time to do the deep engineering,...
...to design and develop two entirely new iPhones...
...more significant than just bigger and better displays.
The design has never been so compelling,...
...undoubtedly making this the biggest advance in the iPhone...
...since we launched the original.